private security has been deployed um
and the reports are that some of them
are wearing balaclavas they're they're
carrying um
[Music]
uh you know they they've been trained to
arrest and uh escort people off vessels
that's what we have
that's what we understand the situation
on some of the vessels
um so our advice to our members is to
stay professional stay on board until we
clarify the legal situation we believe
this is an illegal act it's certainly a
highly questionable and immoral act i
have been in this game 40 years this
industry can shock you on occasions
this is a new low a new low for me in my
experience i'm absolutely stunned my
members are stunned all my staff that i
gathered together this morning to to to
get a briefing and work out an action
plan everybody completely gobsmacked
when did you first hear of this
this morning uh nine o'clock did you
hear did you hear the same way the rest
of the world heard or were you hearing
from employees who who sort of first
told you
our members were contacting the union
they're officials in the union to brief
them about uh a notice that they'd
received to
to uh to tie the ships up and stand by
for a company announcement that's the
first anybody had heard now legal
obligation to consult on redundancy if
that's what this is supposed to be none
of that has taken place it's it's
utterly shameful
and for those uh employees who as we say
are now facing either this the choice of
whether to stay on board uh or to get
off those boats is there a concern that
if they do step off the boats they could
effectively be locked out of their jobs
and that they lose any leverage they
might have had
i think once they're off the ships
that's that's it the job's gone that's
tantamount to accepting i mean they've
been bribed off the ships with
promises of enhanced uh redundancy
nobody knows what those terms are
nobody's seeing the agreements
presumably they'll have to sign
uh you know a settlement agreement we're
urging our members to keep in touch with
us and keep us advised if they're gonna
if they get offered a package consult
the union share any terms of settlement
agreements with us they wouldn't be
valid without professional advice legal
advice anyway we stand by ready to
provide that and we also stand by ready
to support members who want to challenge
this outrageous behavior
now piano have been uh clear to say that
they were making a hundred million pound
losses a year on uh year that that was
being bailed out by their uh
by their uh uh
uh the people who own them so that's dp
world the dubai uh company how much does
that complicate matters that we've got
pno who the employers will presumably
have been uh hired by and dealing with
and also dp world the parent company
um
which seems to have taken the lead on
this will one be blaming the other or
trying to hide behind the other
probably but i've never met a ship owner
that willingly admits to making any
money i mean they never tell you they
make any money they do everything they
can to persuade you
even when it's absolutely self-evident
that some shipping companies have made
huge profits during the covert 19
pandemic but you know you watch them
twist and turn when it comes to trying
to liberate them of their profits to
reward their hard-working staff the
heroes the key workers
they're very the very staff that piano
are sacking this morning have kept this
company's country supplied during the
last two years crucial supply lanes
being kept open and this is how they
reward them having taken as the shadow
minister has just highlighted hundreds
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
of taxpayers money to support that work
and this is how they get rewarded
so are you suggesting that it could be
the case that actually that was a lie
piano haven't been making losses that
they've actually uh been making uh
profits during you know two years of
pandemic and of course the knock-on
effects of brexit
i'm not saying they're lying i'm not
saying that they don't have challenging
uh the piano in itself is has been uh uh
you know struggling it has huge debts to
pension funds
not only the the safer as themselves
there there's two pension funds in
particular but also its own staff so
they have challenges but they have a
fabulously wealthy parent company
um and you know that company is is in
rude health and i would have thought now
is the time for them to get behind the
company support the company shipping has
has to be and is it must be a long-term
investment quick people who are in for a
quick book we don't need them we need
people who are committed this of course
is a very important route it's a very
important
activity for the nation the government
has a strategy maritime 2050 it has a
people uh chapter in that strategy about
building maritime skills for that for a
maritime nation that depends on shipping
and this is just blown
a hole but beneath the water line so i'm
really hoping the government will get in
to get involved with pleasington to note
from the previous uh interview that
there is a meeting plan between the the
minister the secretary of state i would
hope and the company to find out what
the hell is going on yeah i mean a fifth
of their workforce you'll be defending
your uh members uh in their dispute
against that realistically for those 800
who have now found themselves without
jobs
what prospects do they have of finding
uh well either a route back to their own
job or finding some way out of this
i think a lot of them will just call
the reason why there's a strategy by the
way with the people's
people's uh people element to the
strategy to rejuvenate our maritime
skills we have decades of under
investment in shipping skills now that
that that means that we have a very very
poor demographics for for the maritime
skills base in this country a lot of our
people will just call it a day this is
just one kick in the teeth too many i'm
afraid